hey youtubers is Charlie huge news they
just confirmed they're casting a new
Superman actor for Supergirl season 2
like a real like someone you will see on
screen wearing the suit if you didn't
watch Supergirl season 1 they did have
Superman but he was blurry he was
off-screen so when he would appear he
wouldn't really appear in the way you
would expect him to so it was kind of a
disappointment but it was generally
understood that Superman and Batman are
not allowed to appear on the TV shows so
although season 1 moments were really
like a half-measure
like Superman exists in this universe
but don't expect to see him on screen or
interacting with any of the characters
in a meaningful way this is a complete
reversal of that I think it has a lot to
do with bringing him into the CW
universe and then having such a fully
realized group of characters and what's
going on behind the scenes with the
movies with Geoff Johns all the Batman V
Superman stuff Justice League so I think
this is all moving in an awesome
direction and I almost forgot
I know a lot of you are asking what
about Batman if they can do Superman on
the Supergirl TV show does that mean
they can do Batman not right now but I
definitely think they will eventually
get there I think Superman physically
being on screen at the same time that
the movies are happening is a big
reversal of the previous policy of no
Superman no Batman so I think this is
them just kind of jamming their foot in
the door with these two big characters
and I think they'll get the other one
eventually so Superman gonna jam the
door open so that Batman can slip his
way into the TV universe to the thing I
know a lot of you are asking is what
about Tom Welling coming on the show
just reprising his role of Superman just
because it would be a really nice wing
to the fans in the way that the flash TV
show did something so we'll say careful
for spoilers from the flash season 2
because I'll be talking about that they
do things with the TV actors from
previous series John Wesley Shipp plays
a character on the new TV show the
Supergirl TV show kind of does the same
thing with previous actors like it has
the old Supergirl it has Dean Cain but
what I think they're going to do with
this new Superman person they're casting
for Supergirl season 2 is find someone
that we probably haven't seen before I
know it sounds like a bummer but you
have to remember Tom Welling just landed
a new CBS series and he's like the
executive producer so he's both starring
in it and he's making it which is like a
Herculean task so he barely has time
for anything let alone traveling to
Vancouver to film on someone else's TV
show for a couple weeks so yes I do
think that they will find a place for
Tom Welling to come into Supergirl but
it probably won't be as this version of
Superman what might be really awesome is
that they did him is like a Golden Age
version of Superman that was from a
different earth like the way Jay Garrick
is kind of like this old-school version
of the flash compared to the Barry Allen
version of the flash that we know so Tom
Welling will probably end up on the TV
show eventually don't don't worry about
that he's supposed to appear in the
first two episodes so he'll tee up like
whatever the big conflict is of the
season like we learn about zoom in the
first couple of episodes of the flash
season 2 we'll learn about the big
villain of Supergirl season 2 so
Superman sounds like he's going to be a
part of that meaning that he'll come
back every once in a while but he's not
going to be there every single week I
feel like I can see you all nodding your
heads in the background like well yeah
the TV show is called Supergirl it's not
called Superman so Superman is going to
be there every single week because
Superman existed during Supergirl season
1 I think that this version of Superman
will be that same character it's just a
different actor that's going to appear
with his face on screen in the suit so
if you didn't watch season 1 that
version of Superman was fully realized
he had been Superman for a long time the
best way I could describe him is he's
kind of like Tom Wellings version of
Superman you know like he got the suit
at the very end of that series imagine
like 5 years after that after he'd been
Superman for a while then Cara decides
to step up take the mantle you have to
remember that Supergirl of the new
Supergirl TV show is very different from
the Smallville version of Supergirl in
the way that she became Supergirl the
way she came to earth so you kind of
have to forget the plot of Smallville
just consider Smallville is existing on
a different earth remember we have the
multiverse so there's a number of
different ways that they can surface
characters now because it sounds like
since they're doing Superman like
they're really doing Superman they're
going to keep Cara's earth separate from
earth 1 they never really said which
earth she was on we kind of considered
it earth 3 because it was the third
version of earth we've seen but here
getting into flash season 2 spoilers I'm
going to be talking about Jay Garrick so
here we go so john wesley shipp became
the original Jay Garrick the true
version of Jay Garrick from Earth 3 so
if they really wanted to the producers
in the same producers make Supergirl
flash arrow all these DC TV shows with
the exception of
awesome but they could put that jay
garrick flash on cara's earth that they
wanted to and just call that earth 3 but
they haven't said anything about that so
I'm just assuming that everybody's on a
separate earth just a sidestep some of
the logic issues because if Cara was on
Barry's earth then why wouldn't they
talk to each other all the time like
it'd just be really hard for the writers
of each of the shows to accommodate that
so I think we'll see more winking at the
other caters like Cara will talk about
working with Barry like oh my friend
from another earth the flash she'll talk
about him but we'll only see him when
the shows cross over like when we do the
big four and I cross over then everybody
will be on screen together but they
haven't really explained what the story
of that's going to be who the big
villain is like what the conflict is
that requires everyone to be on screen
together the big oh moment that
sets up the crossover it's going to have
to be some big multiverse problem that
will require all of them to come
together some big just a society story
and if you weren't sure what's kind of
going on behind the scenes at Super Girl
Season 2 they're moving to Vancouver so
it'll definitely be a little bit easier
for everyone to cross over but as far as
I know all the same actors are coming
back a lot of people were wondering if
Calista Flockhart was coming back
because she's the most expensive actor
that Supergirl has she you know she gets
paid way more than the other actors do
so unless they figure something out
she's not going to vancouver so cat
grant is still a question mark they
haven't really said anything but I'm
assuming that everybody else is coming
back but they'll still be 23 episodes
they'll premiere in the fall and they'll
be on Mondays so Supergirl will still be
on the same time on the same day
it'll just be on the CW instead of being
on CBS but if they're able to do
Superman just think about the other
stuff that they can probably do now I
think a few of my complaints against the
series we're mostly due to the
requirements of network television it's
just a lot harder for them to do really
weird genre comic-book stories on major
networks than it is on fringe networks
or cable so think about some of the
really weird things that they did during
flash season 2 some of the really
exciting weird things like the way they
pushed into the Speed Force they got a
little supernatural but it's still very
science fictiony I think now that
Supergirl is on the CW they'll be able
to do more things like that they'll have
a little more freedom with the stories
they tell in the way they tell them so a
less texting Superman more talking to
Superman
the texting thing really did bug me but
what about the Kryptonian capsule at the
end of the series there was a big teaser
implying a new character was coming from
Krypton but they didn't really explain
it
and even the actress who plays Supergirl
did not know who's in the capsule the
way they filmed it all you see is just
her looking at the capsule with a
no-shit face so nobody knows who's in
the capsule the producers were trying to
decide in my first thought is that they
were going to bring power girl on that's
who she was going to be she was going to
be from the multiverse but there was
this plot point where a cat grant
promoted Supergirl inside her
organization and said find me a new
assistant because you're not my
assistant anymore so I felt like the
person in the capsule whoever that was
was going to be the new assistant
meaning that it would be a female
character so Power Girl was just like
the first biggest awesome character that
you could think of but also before the
big CW move they were talking about
having Supergirl cross over to the flash
like the flash came to Supergirl so
they're talking about this next season
Supergirl going to the flash but the
showrunner said if she came on the flash
she'd be wearing a different suit so
people were like oh he's probably
talking about Power Girl she'll just be
from a different part of the multiverse
but that's still kind of up in the air
and now that Supergirl is on the CW I
think it'll be a little bit easier for
them to do Supergirl crossovers so just
remains to be seen about that I'm
expecting them to drop a whole bunch of
news at Comic Con they always bring a
bunch of stuff to Comic Con for all
these TV shows so the actors are all
going back to work in a couple weeks so
we'll actually start hearing about
people they're casting stuff that's
going on so there'll be plenty more
videos this summer about what's going on
with the flash Supergirl arrow so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
later tonight I'm actually going to the
warcraft premiere so I'll probably do a
non-spoilery review video first but some
of you might not be able to watch it for
a couple more days so I'll wait to post
my spoilery easter egg review but I've
also got a Deadpool video that I'm going
to post later tonight he's just
destroying x-men apocalypse so I'm gonna
do a funny Deadpool kills the x-men
video while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for
last night's Game of Thrones and you can
click here to learn all about what's
going on with the flash movie in the
flash season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight